well hey you guys welcome back to
flickers of fear it's my little movie
review series that I do on the side so
okay so whenever I hear about a movie
that kind of had a big amount of hype
sort of building up around it usually
after it debuted at a film festival of
some kind I usually try to sort of push
the film up in the rotation so I can
kind of see what the fuss was all about
so when I heard about the movie a
wounded
Fawn uh and I heard that it was kind of
one of the ones that was the most talked
about movies at the Tribeca Festival in
2022 like late 2022 I think that was
also has a 96% critic score on Rotten
Tomatoes and also got nominated for a
fangoria chainsaw award under the best
streaming Premiere movie category it's
actually streaming on shutter at the
moment I think it's also on Amazon Prime
but if you have um shutter you can watch
it as well that's where I watched that's
where I watched it so because of all
that stuff I was like okay well I know I
got to see this especially after I read
that it was kind of like a
surrealistic throwback to maybe like the
Grindhouse movies of the
1970s but also kind of intermingled with
sort of like an art housee flare which
is you know that that's a combination
that's really going to Peak my interest
you know what I mean that sounds like
it's like right up my alley I was also
really interested to see it because um
it was written and directed by Travis
Stevens who was also the guy behind two
other movies that I really liked uh girl
on the third floor from 2019 and Jacob's
wife with Barbara krampton uh from 2021
now I think we've covered both of those
over on our matina show if I'm not
mistaken so we've seen both of these
guys um both these this guy's movies um
but yeah so this guy has like kind of an
aesthetic and a style that I really dig
so I was like really excited to see this
one so a wounded Fawn is set in the
present day but it was shot on actual
film and you can see it like it's the
Grain and everything like that it looks
great um and also it uses it made he
made the interesting choice to use that
real bright red like temper paint
looking blood that they used a lot like
in like giala movies from the ' 60s 70s
um so you know that was a very
deliberate stylistic Choice which I
really liked so the movie kind of gives
this this really cool like Sinister
retro kind of vibe even though like I
said it's said in the present day and I
like that it seems really authentic it's
not at all cuz I know that there's you
know there there's a big thing
particularly in horror uh for the last
10 10 20 years something like that where
it's like everybody wants to you know
stuff to look like it was set in the 70s
or the 80s or whatever and this really
seems like
genuine rather than just trying to copy
a style you know what I'm saying so at
the beginning of the movie we're in this
auction house thing and there's kind of
like a heated bidding war um which
ensues over this little like helenistic
era sculpture um called the wrath of the
I think it's arines is I think you how
you pronounce it um I looked it up and I
was just kind of like it's close enough
um which is kind of like the furies we
would call them the furies of Greek
mythology and there's three of them and
they're kind of getting ready to lay
down some mythological whoop ass on this
like cowering man who's like oh [__] oh
no so these the three figures in this
sculpture who are named electo Meera and
tiphany I think um these are these kind
of like you know vengeful deities I
guess I mean their sole purpose in
mythology is to take revenge on
villainous men pretty much uh so this
sculpture kind of it's not only an
important plot Point as the story goes
on but it's also kind of like a thematic
Touchstone like to the kind of themes
that the movie is exploring as well so
the sculpture uh is ultimately won by
this woman named Kate who buys it for
$150,000 for her client so she takes it
home and she has this really like nice
Swanky very Ultra Modern House like with
all this art in it but not too long
after she gets there with the little
statue in a crate and everything and she
kind of like changes into something more
comfortable and pours herself a glass of
champagne and she's chilling out with
music or whatever um her doorbell rings
and you can tell that she's not really
expecting anybody so she's like huh
what's going on so she answers the door
like very
wearily and she sees one of her fellow
auction attendees whose name is Bruce uh
who's actually played by Josh ruin I
actually recognized him from scare me I
think he wrote wrote and directed that
as well as well as starred in it so
that's cuz I was like immediately I was
like oh that's the dude from scare me
which is also like a pretty decent movie
I think I reviewed that a while back too
so Bruce is standing outside like on the
sidewalk outside her house now he seems
very nice and he just apologizes for
this intrusion and stays like a very
respectful distance away from the front
door so he's not like you know fogging
up on or anything now Bruce explains to
her he's like look my own client um
absolutely has to have this sculpture
and is willing to offer twice what you
paid for it plus an additional $25,000
finders Fe like for you for Kate so
after a little bit of this kind of
negotiation and back and forth she's
like oh well I want a little bit more
money too and he's just like okay they
would probably do that so Kate decides
okay well I'm let the man inside while
she calls her client to sort out like
all the deals you know you know the
details of like this proposed deal
unfortunately for Kate though uh Bruce
is not who he appears to be which starts
to become very clear as he hallucinates
like this kind of lurid red light sort
of appearing in Kate's hallway or
bathroom or something like that he looks
down there and sees it and then he sees
this kind of man-sized owl creature like
a thing with an owl head so which is a
very very striking visual now we learn
as the story goes on this is I guess a
representation of like the evil that
lurks inside Bruce like sort of you know
what I mean I don't want to Super spoil
it but yeah that's kind of what it
represents now shortly after this event
uh which ends badly I shouldn't have to
tell you uh we switch gears a bit and
then we start to follow this woman named
Meredith and she works at a museum she's
like a dosent or something like that and
she has recently kind of freed herself
from a three-year abusive relationship
so she's talking to were two friends who
also work at the Museum and through this
discussion we learned that Meredith has
just met a new guy who she thinks might
be kind of like a serious Prospect uh
they've been on a couple of dates
apparently and this weekend he's invited
her to spend a couple of days like out
at this cabin that he owns in the woods
um with the implication that this will
be like the first time that they're
going to have sex right so Merida's
girlfriends are very excited for her
because they know that it's hard for her
to you know kind of get back back out
there after the shitty relationship she
was in for so long and Meredith herself
seems really hopeful about this I mean
she's in a good place emotionally she's
been going to therapy like to deal with
stuff and she seems to have you know
really benefited from that however when
this new mystery man that she's been
talking about comes to pick Meredith up
for the trip uh it turns out to be Bruce
uh who the audience already knows is a
very very very bad person now on the
drive to the cabin Bruce seems pretty
friendly and like normal enough right
but he has like a few little behavioral
quirks I guess that kind of put Meredith
on her guard right like one of the
things is um she asks oh there's like
this roadside little attraction or stand
or something like that and she's like oh
can we stop there and buy some candy and
there's a bathroom and I have to use the
bathroom and he um pretty much refuses
to do that oh we're so close can't you
hold it like you know what I mean like
he's not overtly shitty about it but
it's pretty obvious that he wants to
remain in control of the situation uh
which you know is making Meredith a
little bit apprehensive it's a little
bit of a red flag when you ask something
reasonable like that and the dude won't
do it you know what I mean so when they
get to the house uh Meredith is a little
bit freaked out by how isolated it is
although when she goes inside um she's
like oh my God it's beautiful in there
it's really cozy it's very Tastefully
decorated it's got like all this
beautiful art in it now uh a particular
interest in regards to Art is the statue
on the coffee table which of course is
the statue we saw earlier at the auction
house uh the Wrath of the arones so
Meredith remembers this piece quite well
as it happens because it came through
her mum to establish Providence like um
a little while before it was sold at
auction and she's actually surprised
that Bruce has it because she's like I
know how much it's sold for and she's I
guess she was kind of like surprised
that he could afford to just drop 150
Grand on this on this little thing um
and he's just like oh it's just it's not
the real one it's just like a really
good reproduction but given her
expertise uh in this area she doesn't
quite buy that uh so that kind of raises
her suspicions a little bit further now
as the evening goes on uh Bruce kind of
seemingly plays The Perfect Host he
makes a really nice dinner and all this
other stuff but Meredith is just
starting to feel like really really on
edge as has is the audience because we
know like what he's up to like she
doesn't know now when she like even
before she goes in the house like when
she's getting her [__] out of the um
trunk of the car or whatever she hears
like what sounds like a phantom woman's
voice like going leave and she's like
what the [__] was that you know what I
mean and then she starts seeing like
flashes or like Visions um she sees like
what appears to be a woman like outside
the Windows like out in the dark woods
and [__] like that and she keeps telling
she like bro there's like somebody
outside your house like your motion
lights came and he's like I don't have
any motion lights and she's like well
something came on out there it's like
there's something out there um so as
this
continues like she maybe thinks it's
like Paranormal or some [__] like that
because you know he doesn't see anything
so his temper like starts you know
getting hotter and hotter and Meredith
starts getting more and more nervous and
he basically tells her straight up well
you're just imagining all of this you
know what I mean it's just like your
standard a haunting kind of thing where
it's just like you stupid woman you
can't like trust the [__] you know
the evidence of your senses and it's
like you're just imagining it and
there's nothing out there so finally the
combination of all of this apparently
ramping up Supernatural activity and uh
Bruce getting more and more douche baggy
that kind of culminates in Meredith
being like dude I do not stay I don't
feel comfortable like staying here with
you like out here in the middle of
nowhere drive me back home or I'm going
to like call a ride chair you know and
that's just the end of it so um he's
pretty Furious about this but he does
actually calmly agree to take her back
to the city however while she's packing
up her stuff she gets a call from one of
her girlfriends see this friend like I
said they both worked at the Museum too
um she had because she was suspicious
about him having the sculpture she sent
a picture of it to one of her friends
and said hey remember when this came
through the museum like it's right here
and the friend says oh uh Not only was
that sculpture stolen but the woman who
bought it at the auction has been
missing since the night of the auction
so now Meredith is really really sure
that she's in terrible terrible danger
so she tries to kind of plate Bruce like
tries to put a neutral face on so he
won't know like what she's found out but
he's not stupid and he's kind of able to
get the jump on her now up to this stage
in the movie the story is played out
pretty much like a standard Thriller
with like a few kind of surrealistic or
possibly paranormal flourishes like
thrown in there right but after this
point it goes off in kind of a lot
Wilder like more nightmarish kind of
direction that I don't really want to
spoil because the way that the narrative
unfolded from this point was pretty
unexpected and ended up like producing
some really awesome like imagery there's
a lot of Gore in this too it's not like
over the top gory and like some of it is
kind of like hyperreal or surrealistic
um and stuff like that so it's not like
a blood bath or nothing
but there's a lot of really beautiful
bizarre imagery in this like I said it's
kind of like surreal and from this point
onward that's kind of where it starts
going more into that territory so I'm
going to say like like a lot of these
kinds of Art House horror films um a
wounded Fawn is not going to be for
everybody um and it seemed like the I've
read some of the shutter reviews and
they were pretty much loved it like it
was five star or one star like what the
[__] did I just watch kind of thing so
it's one of those kind of movies I feel
like it's I I don't know if I'd say it's
like super divisive but it's a little
bit divisive you know what I mean um I
kind of feel like some people might
think that it's like too out there or
maybe too pretentious or too baffling or
whatever to really enjoy fully um
because I will say that its third Act is
kind of Bonkers and really only makes
sense within like a Greek mythology kind
of framework cuz remember I said that
statue was like a thematic Touchstone
and that's what I was talking about um
so if you're not not really down with
kind of bizarre imagery that isn't
overtly explained and like symbolism
that's based around art history or
mythology then you might have a bad time
and you might not know what's going on
but I have to say that movies like this
like I said these right up my alley so I
really really dug it I really liked the
audacity of the thing like the way that
it took this kind of
straightforward cat and mouse premise
you know oh I start dating a new guy and
it turns out he's like a you know he's
crazy or he's like a a murderer or
whatever which is a very common like
Thriller Trope and so it just took that
and then it just kind of piles layers
and layers of these just operatic
visuals and all kind of like allegorical
fantasias and stuff like that like on
top of this very simple straightforward
narrative so I mean at its heart um the
movie is like a pretty much a simple
Revenge story like kind of a maybe like
a supernatural kind of Revenge story but
the style here is really what elevates
it at least in my opinion and I mean I
think the look of the movie is one of
the very best things about it uh
performances also are amazing uh
particularly the two main leads um I
mean the interactions between the two of
them and it's really suspenseful because
like I said you know that this is a bad
guy but she doesn't necessarily know
that so the fact that like watching her
kind of like realize like by incremental
you know stages like how much trouble
she's in is like really suspenseful and
I thought it was really well done so I'm
going to say like if you like your art
your horror kind of like Arty and ballsy
and aren't afraid to kind of embrace the
Mythic and surrealistic aspects of it
then you might really dig it I really
dug it and some other people did too
that I saw like I said some people
really hated it so I don't know how
you're going to fall on that uh so but
if it sounds like something that you
would enjoy uh please head over to
shutter or like I said I'm pretty sure
it's on Amazon Prime too um and check it
out if it sounds like something that you
would be into so that will do it for
this flickers of here I hope you guys
enjoyed please remember like share
subscribe comment all of that kind of
good stuff and I will see you again on
the next one bye